there was only three of us who could  ride mark boone jr  uh david labrava and myself of the leeds  knew how to ride some of them lied and  said they did and then they fell a few  times and realized well you're a liar  so they all had to go to bike school  jesus um  everybody and i would say by the end of  the seven seasons charlie hunnam  probably became the best rider because  he was never off his bike he rode to  work every day we all did but he really  did and uh  yeah i know he became a really good  writer so yeah no i knew how to ride and  i i was called safety first michael  because i would stop so many shots i'd  go cut  cut flanagan  why are you rubbing your [ __ ] feet on  the ground because my boots are slippery  well you do that later wait deal why are  you zipping out of the other line you  gotta stay cut cut